hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
zu einem neuen video ich hoffe natürlich
euch jedes gut wägen heute mal ein
bisschen auf die spur von ganz ganz
vielen dubiosen na ja inwiefern sie fake
sind oder eben doch vielleicht wheels
weiß ich noch nicht es geht auf jeden
fall um diese ganzen mystery box iphone
ps 5 das ding ist nämlich dass mir sehr
viele von euch andauern diese seiten
schicken und mich darum bitten da doch
mal zu bestellen bevor sie das selber
bestellen was ich auch verstehen kann
und da dachte ich mir als das machen wir
heute und wir schicken das ganze erstmal
aus und ich zeige immer folgendermaßen
reihen der tobi hat mir geschrieben also
das ist jetzt zum beispiel eine
nachricht und wie gesagt es gibt mehrere
von diesen seiten
von alex check doch mal dass ihr ab safe
aber irgendwie will man ja trotzdem
wissen was an kommen zumindest wäre es
nicht so teuer was an sich nicht ich
habe glaube ich 63 euro bezahlt kann ich
euch auch gleich mal zeigen aber wir
schauen uns jetzt erst mal zusammen
diese seite an bei der ganzen sache
handelt es sich nämlich um toolbars
punkt kommen ja so sieht das aus ich
finde schon mal irgendwie komisch
also keine ahnung was dieser fette
banner hier oben
zu bedeuten hat oder warum die dänen
gewählt haben keine ahnung du kannst auf
jeden fall runter scrollen und dann
stehen hier direkt mal so absolut dumme
bewertungen die halt sex sind eigentlich
wie zum beispiel dieser hier ich habe
eine box für 69 dollar 990 gekauft ich
öffnete die box und es war ein iphone 12
wahrscheinlich oder das ist wirklich
eine überraschung ich habe einen
wiederbestellt alles klar der garde hat
einfach noch einen bestellt also da muss
ich da auszeit bestellen oh mein gott
diese mysteriöse box ist wirklich
perfekt ich habe die teuerste box
gekauft und geöffnet es ist ein apfel
notizbuch und ein tablet ich sag gleich
mehr dazu wir wollen auf jeden fall mal
runter haben hier dann verschiedene
boxen ich habe mir diese hier gekauft
klicken wir mal drauf das ist die amazon
elektronik karten 23 eur 95 und da
dachte ich mir nehmen wir doch hier
direkt zwei und hier steht ja auch
kaufen sie zusätzliche belohnungen
wenn ich dann halt zwei kaufen das ganze
hab ich bestellt vor gut zwei wochen 45
eur 95 plus transport habe ich auch
nochmal expressversand gewählt damit die
sache schnell ankommen beschleunigt drei
bis acht tage habe ich auch noch mal 15
euro 95 für bezahlt also insgesamt 63
eur 28 wir können hier mal ein bisschen
weiter runter und sehen diesen typ i o
ja das ist einfach so ein rennen typs
voll viele von euch dann schon mal
gesehen mir wird er auch andauernd
vorgeschlagen weil die halt einfach
krass werbung ballern mit dieser seite
oder halt auch mit anderen webseiten wo
dieser typ einfach so eine box auspackt
und also ein voll geile sachen drin du
kannst dann hoch schreiben und kommst
auf diese seite oder halt irgendeine
andere wir haben sehr begrenzte mengen
zu diesem preis weniger als 200 auf
lager
wahrscheinlich wir können hier gern noch
ein bisschen weiter unter scrollen es
sind halt voll viele sachen die die
käufer oder die kunden dazu beeinflussen
sollen hier safe irgendetwas zu kaufen
es ist halt alles viel zu schön um wahr
zu sein würde ich mal schätzen sie
erhalten mindestens 1 und auf geführten
artikel htc apple bluetooth headset und
so weiter und so fort was mir auch
direkt aufgefallen ist die seite hat
kein impressum oder du kannst du
irgendwo sehen wo die sitzen ist ein
bisschen komisch und dann hier so ein
paar rechtstexte einfach stumpf
übersetzt die halt keinen sinn ergeben
das ist alles sehr komisch weil ihr habt
ja gesehen die seite ist komplett auf
deutsch
aber es kommt halt nicht aus deutschland
meine vermutung ist halt irgendwo auf
der welt sitzen die erstellen diese
ganzen seiten ball an die dann raus zum
teil mit deutscher sprache zum teil
sicherlich auch mit anderen sprachen und
schalten dann halt mit
videos die die einfach clown stumpf
werbung auf instagram komisch dass das
geht aber es geht anscheinend ich
persönlich bin auch zum beispiel schon
mal irgendwo aufgetaucht und habe für
irgendwas anscheinend geworben obwohl
ich noch nie von denen gehört habe
vorher die benutzten und einfach mein
gesicht und meine aussagen genauso wie
bei diesem typ den ich euch jetzt hier
nochmal ein blender ich wette der weiß
dass das er dort überall ist aber er
kann einfach nichts gegen machen es ist
aber auch wichtig zu sagen ich habe was
bekommen deswegen das werden wir uns
gleich anschauen aber wir müssen halt
vorher noch ein bisschen hier analyse
betreiben und wenn man jetzt mal tobais
punkt kommen googelt man findet halt
einfach auch keine rats oder irgendwas
dazu wo halt klar ersichtlich ist okay
das ist game das ist fake oder halt eben
auch nicht wir haben auch nicht meine
eigene instagram seite oder facebook
seite was ja jedes unternehmen macht
jetzt zeige ich euch aber mal eben wie
ich trotzdem auf den trichter gekommen
dass es halt safe betrüger sind wobei so
richtig betrug ist vielleicht auch
falsch weil die verschicken schon wahre
aber es ist halt ganz wichtig dass alle
von euch jetzt dieses video schauen dass
sie nicht darauf reinfällt und da
bestellt ich habe nämlich mal diese e
mail bzw das was dahinter steht und den
ich die bestellbestätigung sowie die
versandbestätigung bekommen habe
gegoogelt und zack workshops wave.com
und hier sind dann zum beispiel ganz
ganz viele shops aufgelistet bei denen
man auf keinen fall erstellen sollte
aber trotzdem ist bei mir was angekommen
ich hab euch jetzt glaube ich genug auf
die folter gespannt wir packen das jetzt
erst mal aus und dann erkläre ich euch
meine vermuten hinter diesem ganzen
konnten wir haben ja auf jeden fall dass
ein paket was angekommen ist germany
steht auch hier schön drauf auf der
website stand ja unter anderem ich zeig
euch hier nochmal wir haben
lagerbestände in kalifornien usa
deswegen kommt mein paket auch aus
momentan kommt ich sagen war jung nicht
hongkong ich habe allerdings vor zwei
tagen schon auf paypal da kann man ja so
einen fall eröffnet wenn man mit der
ware nicht einfach schon ist oder wenn
es halt nie geliefert wurde damit man
das geld wieder bekommen und die haben
mir halt direkt die tracking noch mal
dazu geschickt weil die halt darauf
geantwortet haben dass die mir ware
geschickt haben bleibe ich auch super
gerne hier und da steht halt auch
irgendwie so ein paket aus china
aber immerhin haben sie mir geantwortet
die alten california da moment wie
hatte mal kurz
doch das klingt schon sehr amerikanisch
das liegt halt auch nicht viel weswegen
da ist helfe gegen den rotz drin ist
denke ich mal
aber ich will nicht zuviel urteilen weil
vielleicht ist sie ja auch irgendwas
drin was gut ist für leute wir haben
ihre kopfhörer bmi noch nie gehört diese
marke made in seiner fabrik entscheide
ja klar und da ist jetzt halt der
knackpunkt an der ganzen sache ich habe
es mir so mir war das klar wie das
funktioniert also diese kopfhörer gibt
es auf amazon.de spar king für 29 euro
ich hatte sogar gedacht nicht mal und
jetzt stellt euch vor wenn die aus china
kommen was werden ihnen china kosten 10
euro also diese firma bestellt einfach
stumpf die sagen wir haben hier mystery
boxen in amerika kalifornien dann
bestellst du bei den für 60 euro
ich habe ja an sich sogar zwei sachen
bestellt und jetzt erkläre ich euch das
konzept dahinter
dann gehen sie los und dropshipping dir
sozusagen einfach irgendein rotz aus
china für den die wahrscheinlich nicht
mal zehn euro bezahlt haben ball an den
dann nach deutschland und du kriegst
halt das ist jetzt mein mystery ist das
also es kann so kann das ja nicht
laufwerk ist ja klar nur man muss halt
auch sagen es ist halbwegs klug
durchdacht von denen weil die haben ja
jetzt was geschickt die haben ja was
geliefert können das nachweisen ich habe
dafür zwar 63 euro bezahlt und es ist
auch irgendwo irreführend die ware aber
das muss ich jetzt halt auch erstmal
nachweisen und ich denke mal dass viele
keinen bock drauf haben da hinterher zu
gehen und die dann oftmals auch damit
durchkommen und das macht das ganze halt
dann lukrativ in anführungsstrichen für
die es ist halt so traurig aber ich
schwöre ich habe mir das amt von anfang
an genauso gedacht ihr könnt ja jetzt
super gerne mal kommentieren ob ihr auch
schon auf sowas reingefallen seit oder
probleme damit hatte ja bin ich mal
gespannt ob da noch irgendwas kommt ihr
werdet auf jeden fall davon erfahren
ich will auf jeden fall mein geld zurück
kriegen da bin ich mal wirklich gespannt
mit paypal käuferschutz ob ich das halte
sie zurück bekomme das geld ich bin euch
hier super gerne mal noch eine seite ein
die eigentlich genau so aussieht und
genauso aufgebaut ist haben wir zum
beispiel reviews punkt store die
arbeiten mit einem amerikanischen großen
youtube fast drei millionen abonnenten
halt einfach damit keinen plan ob das
weiß aber sonst ist die seite hat auch
genau so aufgebaut wie dieses typs und
es gibt halt wirklich unzählige von
diesen seiten also ich habe bestimmt
schon ihr habt mir schon so viele
geschädigte es uns auch gerne mal in die
beschreibung der liste mit seiten wo ihr
auf keinen fall bestellen sollte diese
seite läuft halt auch über diese
komische oliver adresse oder e mail
adresse von der dann halt e mails kommen
ist halt auch wieder komplett auf
deutsch mit 1000 rechtschreibfehlern und
hier steht sogar eine adresse altstadt
lehel münchen deutschland es ist auf
jeden fall ein sehr vertrauenswürdiges
impressum mit straße postleitzahl alles
da du weißt genau wo die sitzen also
leute was lernen wir daraus last auf
jeden fall die finger von diesen dummen
angeboten die man bei instagram bekommt
oder sonst wo niemand verkauft euch ein
iphone 12 für 69 dollar oder
irgendwelche anderen restposten das kann
ja einfach nicht sein deswegen fällt
nicht darauf rein ich hoffe viele von
euch die jetzt dieses video gesehen
haben müssen das jetzt ich würde mich
mein daumen nach oben freuen abonniert
sehr sehr gerne den kanal und wir sehen
uns die tage wieder leute haut rein